На перший погляд це м'ясо однакове, але різниця в ціні може бути майже удвічі.
Справа в тому, що це м'ясо тварини, яка ніколи в житті не бачила ані неба, ані сонця.
А ця тваринка більш-менш вільно прогулювалася
і не харчувалася кормом з генетично модифікованими інгредієнтами.
Ідея в тому, щоб з першого погляду споживач міг зрозуміти,
в яких умовах провела своє життя тварина перед тим, як стати м’ясопродуктом.
Логотипи і написи про це у виробників різні і це часто вводило в оману.
Рік тому в німецьких супермаркетах запровадили чотирирівневу уніфіковану градацію.
Перший рівень - це так зване "стійлове утримання",
тобто худоба все своє життя провела у стійлах, без пасовищ і сонячного світла,
з дотриманням мінімальних вимог утримання.
Приміром, для свині на 100 кілограмів відводиться лише 0,75 квадратного метра,
а для великої рогатої худоби (понад 220 кг) - майже 2 квадратних метри.
Такій худобі дозволяється давати корм із ГМО і антибіотики для профілактики хвороб.
Майже 90% свіжого м’яса, яке продається в Німеччині, саме таке.
Це - причина одних з найнижчих у ЄС цін на м'ясо.
Але саме за це Німеччину різко критикують.
У країні спалахував не однин скандал довкола ганебних умов для тварин на таких фермах.
Другий рівень - це так зване "стійлове утримання плюс".
Різниця з першим рівнем невелика. По суті, це означає,
що у худоби в стійлах та птиці в курятниках має бути лише на 10% більше місця.
Третій рівень утримання тварин у Німеччині називають Außenklima або Аuslauf.
Це тварини, які мали можливість гуляти на свіжому повітрі, а не провели все життя у хліву.
Крім того, їх годують кормом без ГМО.
Передбачена ще низка приємних для тварин бонусів.
Приміром, свині отримують солому.
А найвищий - четвертий рівень утримання тварин - так і називається: "преміум".
Порівняно з першим рівнем худоба отримує вдвічі більше місця,
тобто для стокілограмової VIP-свині - щонайменше півтора метра.
Кури мають обов’язково вільно гуляти, а не сидіти у клітках,
і їх не годують кормом із генетично модифікованими інгредієнтами.
Крім того, частина кормів має надходити з власного господарства чи з регіону,
де знаходиться ферма.
Яйця в Німеччині теж поділяються на чотири рівні
залежно від того, в яких умовах утримуються кури.
Найвищий рівень - 0. Це біояйця.
Курей годують натуральним кормом,
лікують чи роблять профілактику лише природними засобами без жодної хімії.
Кури вільно гуляють, а у вольєрах має бути не більше 6 курок на квадратний метр.
За ним іде рівень Freilandhaltung,
тобто кури мають свободу пересування, бігають по відведеній для них місцевості
під відкритим небом. А в курятниках має бути не більше 9 курок на квадратний метр.
Ще нижчий рівень - Bodenhaltung - дослівно "підлогове" утримання.
Фактично ці кури завжди перебувають у приміщенні
і у прямому розумінні топчуться одне в одного на голові.
18 курок припадає на один квадратний метр.
Але є ще ганебніший, найнижчий рівень: Käfighaltung,
тобто утримання в маленьких і тісних клітках.
Щоправда, з 2010 року в Німеччині це заборонено.
Натомість спроектовано за новими стандартами так звані клітки для малих груп.
Через 5 років планується і їх заборонити.
Німецькі ферми тепер і самі відмовляються від кліток,
такі яйця не купують і в магазинах їх вже не знайти.
За різними оцінками, нині лише близько 5% німецьких курей-несучок живуть у клітках.
У Німеччині понад чотири мільйони молочних корів,
і ФРН - найбільший виробник молока у Євросоюзі.
Кожен п’ятий літер молока у ЄС - німецький.
Понад 70% усіх молочних корів у Німеччині
- на безприв'язному утриманні: Laufstallhaltung.
Корівники розділені на функціональні зони для їжі, лежання та доїння.
Між ними корови мають вільно пересуватися.
Anbindehaltung, тобто прив'язне утримання, яке раніше було дуже поширене, нині скорочується.
Корови обмежені в русі, схильні частіше хворіти,
і двох квадратних метрів, які їм відводять, явно замало.
Є ще Weidehaltung, коли корови вільно гуляють по пасовиськах.
Де хочуть - там і лягають, мають менше стресу,
травм і запалень суглобів порівняно з тими, що постійно перебувають у корівниках.
Молочні продукти з таких ферм дорожчі, бо вважається, що якість молока краща.
Також стає дедалі більше біогосподарств,
де корови утримуються у найбільш природних
і комфортних умовах та харчуються на біопасовиськах і біокормом.
Таких корів у Німеччині вже приблизно 5%, і з кожним роком
дедалі більш ферм переходять на органічні технології.